wait do you really feel like Filipino
food just belongs in the
track he fills up his plate just like
wasn't even double scoop he doesn't even
need a compe you really that's the
that's the last food you want
unfortunately
[Music]
yes welcome back to careful boys where
we are afraid of everything and today
we're going to talk about the food that
we're the most afraid of the type of
food in fact what is the most overrated
type of food in the world
overrated Chuck a country into the
garbage fun okay let me think I would
say Molecular Gastronomy oh yeah that's
wack that's a country no it's a type of
[__] they always have it in like fine
dining isn't that like what Jose Andre
does I don't I don't know but yeah what
is that it got really popular like
around the time where we finally had
money to spend so during that Trend it
was like really trendy for like it was
like it's eating foam it's like all the
essence of like a plate or something
there's a chef there's a chef named Jose
Andreas who does that he takes like um
duck and he turns it into like cotton
candy foam and [__] yeah I think all of
them kind of do it to show that this is
the level I'm there more chemistry than
anything yeah yeah yeah it's like cuz
you know how like certain the food
changes texture and properties that CT
like like a small version of it would be
like the softboiled EG uhhuh there's
like a specific like temperature where
like when you get your Ramen and that
egg comes like soft that's like a very
very small version of it and and people
they like to like play with different
textures look what I can make this thing
become you know oh but I think I'm too
much of a peasant where I only view food
as like survival sustenance so then when
I pay 300 bucks for something where I'm
just eating root beer float
Pham and I'm like [__] bro sure you
could do Gastronomy at home or whatever
yeah putw on vanilla ice
cream me and Nikki went to this place
called called bizar it was by that Chef
I was talking about oh I want to go
there bizarre Meats yeah but dude it's
it's not good it's no it's just I was
hungry after that's Nevada no it was in
LA oh yeah is it SLS yeah by the SLS
Hotel yeah I think I have to when I go
find dining I have to like know I'm
walking into an art gallery like I can't
be there like I'm a [__] grub
dude what did you have there everything
I've been there like four times this
every time it wasn't my choice it was
like friend's birthday thing all that
kind of [__] but did they pay though uh
one of the times yes one of the times no
yeah to pay 300 bucks you never know I
remember my ex used to work there so we
used to get discounts and we would order
like all these like like the cotton
candy F gr yes that yeah and it was like
that sounds good just eat F gr you know
oh I know a country I could dump into
the trash can if I had to yeah dump it
Thailand
Thailand I do I do like Thai food but I
think if I had um Thai food is [__]
fire if I had if I had Vietnamese food
that's already close enough oh like
let's say if you have really somebody's
going to get offended how about this lot
I think a country country like Vietnam
Vietnamese and Tha and Thailand what you
you dump in a trash can don't don't put
me don't put me in that situation you
have to which well that's easy I'm V so
I got V ask ask Nick I told you who
would you dump in a trash can vames or
Thailand well but you have to that's my
country I grew up on it's different but
you know what's weird is a lot of the
Thai restaurants here are different from
food in Thailand whereas in Vietnamese
cuisine I feel like it's kind of similar
and I I I think that's because Thai food
in America it's more like a marketing
plan for the government to encourage
tourism to Thailand so they created all
these dishes for Americans but I think
Bart's asking which country do you want
to put in the trash can I would dump
Vietnam because of your connection
thanks for the history lesson okay so we
Balan each other out cuz you know how
like all Cuisines there's kind of like
they kind of come in like paars a little
bit like there's Japanese food and then
Korean food is kind of like spicy
Japanese food like everything kind of
comes in
pairs so out of all the pairs you have
to dump one of them in the trash I would
put vietnames food in the trash between
Tai and
between time yeah yeah somebody's going
to get this is a skip bis take dude that
was who Skip
B you're just being inflammatory dude no
because that's how like okay Mexican
food El Salvadorian food right like
they're like there's they always come in
these little pairs you got to like dump
one of them one of them what you dump in
somebody between salvi and probably
salvi wait do you really feel like
Filipino food do belongs in the
track Steve fills up his plate he fills
up his plate just like Steve was
double scoop he doesn't even need to
compare you really that's the that's the
last food you want
unfortunately
yes wait what's hey I don't ever want to
see you order jollybee ever again no I
won't well I'll order it so I can throw
it away you're talking about like at a
Filipino party and they gave you a plate
of food nothing you don't like nothing
on that plate I like the way that it
goes in the
garbage I like the way you could stuff
it to the bottom yeah it's kind of like
real heavy yeah it's kind of like when
I'm when I get like a big package of kab
bang noodles It just fits in the [__]
trash better than almost anything you
could
buy hey I have to say though between uh
Filipino and Chinese and a lot of the
other Southeast Asians the way that
Filipinos do crispy pork like their
lechan [__] fire theis pork I don't
know why it's done he throw gag a little
I don't know how they do like it's like
a pork Grind On Top oh man and then it's
so good yeah what's so like you've had
adobo you've had pan I've been all the
Ducks all of them Filipino food or
Kinder bang
noodles oh [__] give me a gun dude you
know what I'll say about Filipino food
there there's definitely versions of it
like depending on what Filipino party
I'm at well there's it's the same item
but it tastes very different from like
house to house like my buddy yeah he
makes his his sister makes this
delicious Filipino spaghetti but then
one of our neighbors brought us some
Filipino spaghetti and I was expecting
it to taste just like it and I was like
I can't eat this you're like this is
Italian spaghetti this is not even good
like this is just awful spaghetti but my
buddy's Filipino spaghetti is like oh
dude I could eat a whole [__] tub of
this so is it Nikki's family that has
bad Filipino food or you've been to lots
of different Filipino food places in
I've been to a bunch of different
Filipino I mean well cuz my cuz it's
like her family right like her grandma
Cooks It Come hey come over to her
Grandma makes garbage all the time you
just call it garbage now and so do her
ants hey come over to Nina's Nina's
mom's house I want I I literally want to
bring you over to my mother-in-law's
house now can I come you don't have a
distaste for it you're actually going to
eat it and I can't have that is it is it
cool if I eat like
this we like I'm just ready to go like
in case I just got to go she she really
likes what do you think what do you
think uh Filipino food could benefit
from to be better for you what do you
think
better
ingredients um yeah better preparation
you know oh [__] better recip don't just
throw a bunch of stuff into a bowl and
mix it up like what
the I can't wait till we become a next
shark article I'm trying to build a real
what I'm doing I'm trying to build a
real right now and then we slam dunk
like hey I would rather eat like [__]
Pizza flavored cheit that sounds bomb
that's that's not fair that sounds
really good that's good that sounds
really good hey what would you guys
throw in trash cans not Thai food I'm
the only one that answered Steve's
question well he said Filipino food you
said Thai um he also said kab bang
noodles that's which is a a Cuisine by
the way like if someone deleted tie from
my menu it would not affect my life one
really Double Down Bart Double Down have
you had Thai sausage with sticky rice
yeah I do I love mango with sticky rice
I love Thai Boat noodles I love a lot of
Thai things I love uh what's that
[__] um what's the steak where it's
crying beef or some [__] cry tiger I
love cry I love those things but that's
like a couple of things versus like I
love a [__] ton of Vietnamese food or a
[__] ton of Korean food four Vietnamese
dishes Bing b b Bing and ging ging holy
[__] that was six he named six just now
that is how it would sound if I
[Laughter]
was one of my favorite okay boomba I
love bun R I
love bro [__] uh what are the the egg
noodle like The Chew child style noodles
those are bomb when I start thinking
about throwing away
food like I go oh but I tasted the best
version of that and it's pretty bomb I
can't toss that anymore I I I I would
agree about but it's the cuisine though
you know the whole thing yeah I would
agree about one person doesn't one one
dish doesn't save the whole Cuisine wait
what's the one that you would throw away
I think I would agree about Thai food
because it's oh my God it's bomb but
it's not bomb enough to where I eat it
as a staple I'll eat it so I think the
thing with Thai food is it's good and um
I'll eat it like once every 3 months
whereas Vietnamese food I'll eat it
every week wow like if someone took away
Japanese food from me that's like KATU
Sushi Ramen it's like right but if
someone took away Thai food it's just a
couple things I'm like I'll move on
something else know py you just a couple
things what you just did was a couple
things about by the way about Japanese
food it's a couple things but those
things are so important though well
exactly but dude I actually used to eat
Thai food every week in high school and
then during college I got I was just
like done with it if you took Curry from
me I I can't handle it I I have to have
Tha food every every couple Curry is
[__]
okay why don't we just go to like
different food cuz I feel like why are
we all dunking Asian food in the trash
okay the one that I would throw we Subs
I [__] hate Subs you hate submarine
Sandwiches really what about a hot one I
don't give a [__] it's hot trash I could
throw that away too sorry it's hot trash
to me dude I'm throwing Taco Bell all
the way in the yes wo whoo whoo whoo
hold on no throw it away stepping on it
yeah out of the pairings I'm keeping Del
Taco chucking Taco Bell is that but then
that's not a food type that's like a
specific by the way that's a cop out
that's one that's one that's one that's
that's a cop out can't believe you guys
are do Del Taco Brothers you got to
blanket a nation I I used to be the only
one no you got to offend someone you got
to offend the
nation we got to take after the
marketing genius Nigel of [__] Uncle
Roger who recently talk [__] about La
food we got to pop off I'm going to say
I'm cutting out Russian food really is
not good oh I think that's a good I
never tried it borch is that what it is
bch is in there thought they so like the
bread wine that they got bread wine is
that a choice that frequently comes up
in your life like Russian food or
something else no more Russian salad
dressing right that's over oh yeah
that's it what do they what do they eat
like uh caviar and then just like vodka
you know what's random about Russia they
got a lot of Philadelphia cheese rolls
over I mean cream uh the sushi you know
the Philadelphia rolls the cream cheese
why for some reason every spot sell
Sushi and for some I'm going to get
[__] and for some reason they got
Philadelphia rolls in every single one
of those no way in Russia have you tried
moose tongue no I haven't I think I was
watching chef's table or something one
of those cooking shows and then the chef
was like petting his MSE and then they
Cuts straight to a plate full of moose
tongue wow that's a that's a cut oh I
know what I can do without French food
oh my favorite food in France was
Italian food okay are saying of all the
European countries though because I
still think French food is higher in the
European count like I haven't well I
haven't had outside of uh Italian
Austrian German German yeah I'm not
getting rid of what about Spanish food
throwing that in a trash only because
they don't have hot sauce or spicy stuff
I think we have a better version of it
you know I've never had Spanish food
Spanish food is still good in a lot of
Rand p is still pretty good that's just
fried rice bro the Tapas cultures is
still pretty good it's tough cuz we have
we'd be looking at everything from an
American lens I don't know what Spanish
is every time I've had paa it was in
America and it was Bland as [__] yeah
I'm just like eh what about what about
British food is there even British food
like smash peas and [__] I like I like a
good shepherd's pie I like British
breakfast I like pie slaps bro fish and
chips you would cut out
Thailand because Vietnam exists that's
true but also I'll say this actually
going back to Thailand there's a lot of
like the pan the pan fried rice noodles
that do you can get that from like like
you know like beef cha fun you can get
that from like there's other adjacent
things I throw away Chinese food too
really wow you need to slow your roll
what about German food what about like
beef stroganov who gives a [__] I love
winter snitel see I like German food
that's lame dude when I was in Austria
for like a whole ass month and I what
were the bangers what were the hitters
snitel andit are but that's
KATU pork knuckle what do they what do
they breed it with no but he could throw
it away because you know we still got
costume in Japan no that's not but also
though kind of better shinil is good
it's just you know it's they got BR
worst BR worst their sausages are fire I
like I think you ever crave a sausage
though you're not just craving a sa I do
sometimes Europe does really good baked
[__] cuz that's home for them you throw
a French cuisine you throw away stuff
like a a French bread oh dude okay does
that mean you throw away half a
Vietnamese food you thow you throw away
a yeah they're croissants and like
they're pastries oh keep the French keep
the French get throw you could leave
French bro I you throw away the Germans
throw away the Germans you got to leave
the French I like how Barton is just
like just [__] Thailand
dude how can we keep [__] Thailand I
need my shepherd's pie but the entire
nation can go I don't think I can throw
away Thailand bro I can't throw away
Thailand Thailand Okay British food or
Thailand I think Thailand's hey Indian
food or Thai food for you one's going in
the trash know that's your [__] so which
so my [__] is Mexican food number one he
likes all the spicy and then two three
is tied between Thai food and and Indian
so all the spicy [__] get spicy [__]
damn dude that's real so the one you
throw away gets replaced with Filipino
food forever
I I'd have to go Thai food because I eat
it way more than Indian food I feel like
Indian food in America basically it's so
buttery in like it's really buttery but
also they [__] you so hard they give you
like two cubes of chicken you get
chicken chal they give you two cubes of
chicken ridiculous two Thai food places
they dump the chicken in there dude
they're they're you're right you're
right they do yeah no but he's dumping
Thailand yeah he dumps all Thailand cuz
he wants to eat a hot dog dude the the
ground chicken and pork Oh that [__] is
so good over rice and an egg you can't
beat that hey rank rank Chinese Hong
Kong and Taiwanese food he want to eat a
Wy Stadium hot dog Hong Kong Taiwanese
and then put a shepherd's pie in there
oh [__] oh you know what I could do
without Taiwanese food I could do
without T food too oh Taiwanese food the
only thing I like that is the beef
noodle soup but mainland China has that
too and then um their pork chop rice I
like so those are the two things I
usually eat that's to be fair mainland
China all Taiwanese food I think could
take the L yeah I think you're right see
hot dude I could throw I only like
Taiwanese F because of nostalgia yeah
you grew up on it but it's not even
really like I really like are you
telling me you're throwing away stinky
tofu this guy away stinky tofu good good
i' rather have a hot dog it's already
thrown away technically I'd rather have
a hot dog dude is than a stinky tofu
putting that in trash is so
redundancy he's like sneaky tofu or
Thailand so the best Thailand out of the
chineses I think the best fried things
are like the salt and pepper anything
right salt and pepper wings salt and
pepper calamari salt pepper tofu yeah
yeah yeah so that salt and pepper tofu
is way better than stinky tofu cuz it's
one of the best I was okay so I those
three I would say Hong Kong Hong Kong
Hong Kong is good number one I think and
shepherd's pie cuz he told me you have
to and then and then Taiwanese food and
then Chinese food just because I've seen
stir Fred meal worms I don't want to eat
that wait so for scale would you would
you delete all of Thailand food to keep
just stinky tofu oh what do you mean
Taiwan or Thailand's food Thailand would
you let go of just for stinky t saky
been duning on this whole no I like
Thailand I like Thai food way better
than sneaky toe food really oh no way we
found it we found it yeah I mean I love
Thai food Tha but just it doesn't affect
me as much what is the base is the base
like a Costco hot dog and anything under
that is [__] or like what is the average
prob Pizza Pockets no well Costco Pizza
flavor cheese Costco hot dog is really
good also because of the price it's true
if it's $15 then all of a sudden I don't
give a [__] about that okay you can only
save one barbecue American barbecue
Brazilian barbecue Korean barbecue
Japanese barbecue that's a good question
Korean barbecue I got to go Korean
barbecue cuz it comes with 7,000 other
dishes dude that's hard I would save
Japanese barbecue man what's the
difference I don't even know I like
yukaku better
than I get it I would say American
barbecue not even to whatever you know
what if I can't have a [__] Burger
again [__]
you damn
that's a good question oh but dude
freaking Phils Barbecue when it comes to
like ribs and yeah buddy that's hard and
and like what about like um the the
sandwich with the made of pork shredded
pork the [__] isk pork sandwich oh
that's [__] undefeated I do love
American barbecue is the best American
food or you know what's amazing that I
don't get enough of is Cajun food oh yes
sir like New Orleans style food like I
feel like that's some of the best
tasting food jumas I think it's because
there's not enough people here opening
those restaurants like the closest thing
was kind of boiling crab cuz when I had
Cajun food in the South it was like this
is what it's supposed to taste like and
when you have it in California you're
like it just tastes kind of Mexican it's
c is cinjun and Creo food similar yeah I
think so it's the same is
interchangeable shout outs to taste buds
in Vegas I ate their uh barbecued oxtail
that [__] was [__] crazy how does it
how is it served over a better R and
gravy so it just looks like chopped up
Meats it was just like yeah and then it
had like chunks of meat on Bones it was
crazy good and then uh but I did wait
like 45 minutes and the guy came out and
he was like we take our time here and I
was like that was a long time to wait
but it was worth it yeah what what about
steak houses you guys throwing steak
hous in trash rush I probably throwing
Black Angus in the trash we ain't in a
rush do you guys think steakhouses are
over pick two pick two will throw one
away which steak house it's rare to find
one better than
how I cook in my that's how I feel like
I feel like I could always cook a steak
better or just get unless it's Brazilian
barbecue yeah bra but that's not really
a steak house I would say like MOS
[__] Black
Angus Morton out you really said it in
that order mastros is good but it's just
like you just feel like I could just
make this at the house and save $10,000
I've never been to Ruth's Chris is
really good Ruth's Chris is pretty fun
well what if it's like when you have
those dry age a long time you can't
really do that at home yeah like hella
long dry age type [__] if you have the
right equipment you can you can yeah
Nick you can also make beer in your
garage
Nick n people have dry agers it's
actually not that hard how many times
you cook a tomaha who has a dry Ager
here I don't but I don't like Dr meat
like that though if I did I would get
one oh you don't like that you don't
like it well I'd rather have just a
regular [__] steak dude have you had
one of APL steaks though no that's
different level though that will will
[__] knock us he's barbecue genius
Adam Perry Lane is probably one of the
best [__] pit Masters out there why
don't you ever take us it's a [__]
him and Dave go all the time [__] raise
your hand if you want BART to take us
it's a [__] Holy Experience dude put
hand eating his food is [__] would
you guys toss Greek food in the trash
kind of I might I like a good gyro I
like Greek food I think that's the end
of this I like a Sharma better dude no I
I actually like um Armenian style of
that cuz there's this place we go to
Sahara and Pasadena oh bro come on
brother that's oh Mediterranean food you
guys been to carne Val in um Studio City
[__] delicious it's like familyowned
really good I'm not getting rid of
Kebabs I'll tell you that nope no
sir